Now it is time for "Hashtags,"
everybody. Here we go.
♪ Hashtags ♪
♪♪
-We do this thing every week
where I send out a hashtag
and I ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
So, since it's
St. Patrick's Day
and we all want
to go out and party
but we have to wait
a few more months,
I thought we could reminisce.
So I sent out the hashtag
#PartyFail,
where I asked you guys
to tweet out
some of your best party stories.
Within minutes,
it was a trending topic,
so thank you for playing along.
And now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
#PartyFail responses
from you guys.
This first one is from
@RezendesNick. He says...
[ Laughter ]
That's a bummer.
This one's from @morning-skinny.
They say...
It's like, "Who would be the --
Ah, okay, it's the --
the green house."
This one's from @jbellpoe.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Not a good look.
This one's from @ajathefairy.
She says...
It's like...
"You don't live here?"
This is from @notjustarand0.
He says...
[ Laughter ]
That's a bummer.
That is a PartyFail there, man.
This one's from @ItsFlyToBeChey.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
That's great! Oh, my God.
That should have been on tape.
That's really good.
[ Laughs ]
"Whoa!"
That makes me laugh.
This last one's @writtenby-jvb.
She says...
There you have it. Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more
of our favorites, go to
tonightshow.com/hashtags.